Apple's new flagship iPhone is the most
expensive phone it has ever produced the
tech giant unveiled its thousand-dollar
iPhone 10 yesterday in a highly
publicized rollout Apple also introduced
two less expensive models and updated
its SmartWatch and TV John Blackstone is
at Apple's new headquarters in Cupertino
California with why the new phone is
already facing some criticism John I
want to hear all about it
good morning well this brand new
building behind me is the lobby -
Apple's new Steve Jobs theater it's as
high-tech as the company's new iPhone 10
which pre-orders begin early next month
now the new phone features facial
recognition wireless charging and of
course takes better pictures but is all
that worth the hefty price tag inside
its sleek new Steve Jobs theater Apple
was looking to score a perfect 10 one
decade after it debuted the first iPhone
the company unveiled the iPhone 10 it is
the biggest leap forward since the
original iPhone the phone is unlocked
using facial recognition instead of a
fingerprint Apple has also eliminated
the home button creating a larger
edge-to-edge screen and the phone is now
designed for wireless charging but some
experts question whether the innovations
go far enough the iPhone 10 still feels
like a smart phone it feels like many
other smart phones from what I've seen
the 10 also costs twice what the
original iPhone did $1000 smart phone
yeah it's a lot of money and when you
have phones that cost half that n even
ones that Apple makes that are hundreds
of dollars less what are you getting for
that I don't think a lot of people are
gonna go for those apple also unveiled
the slightly less expensive iPhone 8 and
a larger iPhone made plus with improved
cameras and speakers there's a lot at
stake for the company customers bought
more than 1.2 billion iPhones in the
last decade but many passed on the
iPhone 7 because it was too similar to
the 6 and Apple's revenues fell for the
first time since 2001
experts say Apple may be hampered by its
past success having already made some
giant strides it feels more like
incremental steps than something where
they introduced something brand new and
completely different
Apple is also focusing on the wearables
market the the watch will no longer need
to be paired with your phone in order to
make and receive calls it will have its
own cell service built-in so the age of
the two-way wireless wrist communicator
may finally be here
Gayle right Wow all right John
Blackstone well anybody at the table
gonna get the iPhone 10 by anybody you
Charlie right at some point yeah at some
point you can't do anything great
without people criticizing you you know
it's a step it's the next step in the
phone it's expensive but you're making
innovation
I hear you Nora I hear you yeah